this is reformed is it bad I'm growing
numb to this you know um when I watch
this show
especially after being away from it for
so long I love I love these rules but I
love all the options they open up when
every year sir told something new like
this is how something works I get
excited because it's like oh what else
can they do with this what are the
opportunities
amethyst for something like this where
you know they can regenerate and if
anything it you need time to regenerate
and be put back together you know pearl
took two weeks and now they bring it
back here or you have it all he's
slightly like Emily yeah you keep
getting killed by this thing which is
already pretty free compost again yeah
which is already free honey bunny dirty
yeah
but whenever she comes back it's like
all the cool things you can do to this
and they they do it every single time
sometimes like one arm would be big one
leg will be big sometimes she'll come
back looking like pearl and or if you'll
have all feet and the way and the way
she moves every single time that's what
I like with the animation this one I
thought was really good and not just
with the expressions which I really
liked in this one but the UM anytime she
comes back in new for if she moves
different even when she comes back as
prochik and moves like pearl and
twirling around and stuff and I I really
love that I love that attention to
detail and it just makes it more fun and
more flowing but it's really just a
metaphor for accepting who you really
are I didn't get that at all I think of
real wait really into this oh maybe I'm
reading too much yeah no no don't say
that don't listen and I I don't know I
have a drinking weird um that was also
very good message obviously um and there
was a message but but it's also funny I
like see him go through her room I
always hope the colors in her room I'm
very much a cold color person so I love
seeing those colors uh and I'm not a
purple person so I think if it's mixed
with like blue and then blues my
favorite color so I mean as you can tell
no but yeah if it's mixed with that you
know I'm fine with it um purple oh I
love purple thanks Vicki um it ya know I
like I like blue a lot i purple though
actually purple and shades of pink maybe
my least favorite color I can see the
pink and I never like I look at a sunset
and I vomit actually a sunsets but the
only paint thing they actually yellows
and browns I don't lie sir a yellow
orange and brown that combination I
don't really go yellow green as a
combination I don't like that swamp
Queen yeah I don't like that either but
uh but anyway side right here now let's
talk about the color wheels yeah that's
what you to Diane um but uh yeah I
thought this was again a good salad
episode that Sarah showed different
things you can do with the regeneration
but also taught a nice moral um I said
the expressions in this one I really
like it got really big and huge
especially with the yelling but not ren
and stimpy huge like it's still really
complimented the emotions of the
characters even that little smile she
has at the end what you know I thought
that was a nice little touch um and I'm
gonna take a wild guess and say when
they were talking about witch crying
breakfast friends are you who also watch
a show where all they do is cry and said
they gotta be talking about themselves
all right they have to be talking about
themselves like that's not the
criticisms they got or something
what was the criticism they get that uh
look at the show the time about which
crying breakfast friends are you and
this just says that shows really their
and cartoons really weird why would you
watch a show where all everybody does is
cry
they do nothing but cry on the show no
not nothing I mean I'm sure it's like a
criticism whatever but certainly a show
that addresses emotions and there's a
lot of people that you know pick cry
when I got the emotions and stuff I mean
that's I don't know I feel like I feel
like that's gotta be a lie I was just in
it for the monster of the week Alice
assists um yeah I got nothing that man I
just thought it was a joke I I think
what do you guys I'm curious your guys
with file I leave them
it's cuz I audience what do you have to
say well because like with almost
anything I don't keep fat on top of fan
bases uh I shouldn't try to avoid
fandoms like the play yeah but me too I
find it just ends up clouding my own
opinion and it yeah I'd just rather not
I'm not I'm not saying any fandoms bad
or worse than the other but I find
whenever I start getting involved and
reading up on the fandoms I'm just like
no okay it starts messing with my own
opinion of the show good or bad like
it's just I'd rather just watch it in a
nice little bubble I like talking to a
person about it like you know this I
really like I liked on to a person like
into a huge group of people who went
into a message board it's just not my
bandage your thing oh great its
community is sharing with you know mass
public like I think it says a lot of
about a fandom or just a group in
general when you see what everybody's
are thought about it or how opinions
sway or whatever whatever a joke it's
just not my thing it's like I don't pay
attention really to anime fandoms at all
and I'll watch certain anime shows not
like them I'll watch certain shows I
love them but by post most looks like
it's like garbage or I can't believe you
two you don't watch a lot of anime and
I'm like that that's my favorite is a
yeah somebody's bought like a number of
people when I said I liked sword art
online we're just like I get it you know
watch a lot of anime it's okay he has an
anime will Knight you every week well
group of friends I come over and what I
posted I posted the number of shows that
I've actually watched in the number of
people who were saying that publicly
apologize cuz like I've seen a this
do all the costumes at conventions and
stuff like you know what like 98% of
them are I know cuz I don't I'd say I
know 50% cuz there's certain shows that
I just haven't seen the or that are out
right now that I'm not watching and but
but yeah so but it was just a clear
example like this is why I don't follow
the fandoms I like anime I don't like
talking to anime fans plural like I've
met plenty of I've met plenty in anime
fan that I've talked to one-on-one and
like you said it's perfectly reasonable
it you get anime fans and it all gets
clique-ish in this giant group and then
it's just all about we want to shame you
for liking or not liking certain things
it's a go away well at the MS group
psychology and mentality instead of even
how you act with a person or by yourself
is gonna be very different compared I
act in a group um so if it's really your
thing
that's fine I I think it's it's even
kind of fun to explore and stuff like
that I think my fear in a fandom and
you're enjoying it go nuts not my thing
yeah I um I tend to just not want to
know what people are thinking in the
fandom I'd rather just form my own
opinion separate so but uh but no I
thought this was this be who you are and
what a great metaphor because their
bodies are all different on the outside
but on the inside they're gems aren't we
all gems no you're not that sucks
no you're more like Louis craggly little
pebbles that I kick along the side of
the road you know pelvis turret off is
that too okay no she did but she's that
she does bring me this on you are
one-tenth as cool as amethyst then you
can say something no but that does
connect to something here which I did
canvasser which I like amethyst is out
of the three of them is kind of the most
of an outsider and you know her history
no her backstory and she was brought in
she's I guess the youngest out of all of
them uh you know he's got her I yeah I
mean we even saw him in that flashback
one I mean she's like a little kid or
you know looks like a little kid where
the other two are growing up um so it's
one of those things where I think there
is that's a good character to do it with
because you can kind of identify with
she is kind of the outsider so finding
her a genuine little tougher this whole
show seems to be based around identity
that's always what I said and I really
like it for that I think again that's
why it has that's why I think it's great
for kids that's why I think it's
connected so well with adults I think
right now especially with the internet
identity is why men really huge they
mentioned gay things that they're for
the corrupt they oh um I mean and the
show find so many imaginative
interesting ways to discuss identity and
relationships and and so forth um and
yeah that that's what pulled me to it
that's what I said me we should do V
logs on this because though not just
what they're talking about but the way
they're talking on the family well
animated well put together show is the
nice bonus yeah um so but that is a nice
thing you can watch it as you know as an
adult or as a kid and you can get into
the monsters they punch and the funny
lines and the silliness or you can also
get into New York's it works because
sometimes like their shows out there
where I really love the story or I
really love the message but I hate the
animation or there's some there's some
shows I've watched I'm like wow what a
terrible story but that was gorgeous
yeah um that happens a lot in anime okay
um so it this one complete package yeah
it really seems tightly put together
yeah a very few complaints and again
because they're so short like a venture
time uh you have to you can't
much you have to get to the meat of it
really fast and you have to really focus
on what's important uh statement of
theme but not just that I mean like
their emotional journey as well like has
to be really direct while mixing in all
this comedy and imagination and story
artists and just the all-around
continuing story it's it's tough but
they really balance it out well well
what she talked about this show yeah we
know
forgive us we're getting bad at this
yeah we gotta we always get make out
with more laughs we gotta go on topic so
um I think guess what they're stopped
overhead that's your second favorite
color
puce mine's plaid that's not a color ya
know